Bonjour !
Bienvenu sur le tournage
du court-métrage, L’AUTRE MOI.
Y’a pas besoin de ça,
pas besoin de violence.
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
C’est quoi ce tournage ?
Qu’est-ce t’as toi à me filmer
depuis une demi-heure ?
Il commence à marcher, on le suit
et quand il arrive au niveau de JH
là on arrête le focus.
C’est un court-métrage qui parle
du fait de se lancer
et d’essayer d’avoir le courage
de se donner les moyens
d’aller au bout de ses rêves.
C’est une thématique
que j’aime beaucoup
parce qu’à un moment,
j’ai dû faire aussi un choix
Qui est de se dire,
je vais faire un métier qui existe pas
à l’époque en tout cas.
Donc j’ai arrêté mes études
j’ai arrêté de travailler
pour des employeurs
C’est un moment
très bizarre de la vie.
Mais non mais du coup,
tu dois te lancer, ce soir
Quoi ? Non attends,
je suis pas prêt.
Je peux pas me lancer ce soir
c’est pas possible,
j’ai pas de texte j’ai rien.
Je vais te coacher.
Ce soir tu montes sur scène.
On est trop cools.
En fait au fonds,
tous les deux sont drôles.
Tous les deux ont
toujours eu ce truc là.
C’est juste qu’à un moment
y’a eu un événement
Et je pense qu’en fait
dans la vie des gens,
ils savent de quoi je parle.
Mais y’a eu des petits trucs,
où tu t’es dis
je vais essayer ça,
je vais tester ça, ça joue à rien.
J’ai symbolisé ça par
une rencontre avec Jamel Debbouze
Le mec dit franchement je suis marrant
Toi tu dis “ fais-moi rire”
ou un truc comme ça ?
Ouais “prouve-le”.
Et là je désamorce
en disant, je déconne frérot
Viens le mardi à 18h
et je me suis dit,
imagine  quelqu’un il dit
Oh tiens je vais lui demander un contact.
L’autre qui dit
“je m’en fous je laisse passer”.
Ce petit moment charnière
Donc du coup imaginons
que ces personnes se divisent à ce moment-là.
et puis se retrouvent
un peu plus tard.
En fait, c’est là où
nos vies sont différentes.
T’es pas mon moi du futur
ou je sais pas quoi
J’y étais à l’anniversaire de Tib
Et j’ai croisé Jamel
sauf que
On a pas discuté
Au final y’en a un qui est épanoui
mais qui est allé
trop loin dans son arrogance
et l’autre qui  déprime
un peu dans son travail
c’est ça la grosse différence
mais c’est quand même
la même personne.
Et là il manque la bite,
donc je vais te la faire s’il te plaît.
Allé laisse-moi une fois
Ils ont en commun Leila, effectivement
C’était important pour moi d’avoir
une histoire aussi pour Dji
faut quelque chose qu’il est perdu
quand il est arrivé dans ses rêves etc
il est fait aussi des mauvais choix
Leila c’est
une âme d’artiste
qui est heureuse et consciente d’être en vie
et qui pousse son copain,
JH, à aller de l’avant
et à faire ce qu’i lui fait peur.
Elle sent que son mec
n’est pas tout à fait lui-même.
Elle comprend pas trop ce qui se passe.
Mon personnage ne le voit pas comme
quelque chose qui va pas entre-nous
Mais plus se soucie de
ce que JH a dans la tête.
Et donc Leila représente ça
c’est ce qu’il a
perdu lui en chemin.
Y’a une phrase que j’ai dit
C’est bien de faire rire des gens
mais si tu fais pas rire la bonne personne,
à quoi ça sert ?
Parfois tu te lances dans ton art
C’est la thématique du film Whiplash
que j’adore.
C’est tu veux te lancer à fond
Mais est-ce que ça te rend heureux ?
J’en parle aussi dans
mon court-métrage, Fais un voeu
C’est quelqu’un qui perd un peu tous ses rêves
mais y’en a des nouveaux
qui vont apparaître.
Et qui sont représenté par
ta compagne, ton compagnon
ta famille, tes amis
donc il ne faut pas se perdre en route.
C’est parti mesdames et messieurs,
faites du bruit pour Doully
J’ai choisi le stand-up,
parce que je connais assez bien le milieu
j’ai pleins d’amis qui font du stand-up
Y’a un côté encore plus
se lancer tout seul
être face à un public
y’a un côté un peu à nu.
d’ailleurs en parlant stand-up
c’est quoi les conseilles
pour monter sur scène ?
Pour s’améliorer, il faut jouer souvent
Pour jouer souvent,
il faut trouver des endroits où jouer
Donc ça déjà c’est pas facile
Parce qu’il y a pas
tant de soirée que ça.
Et puis en trois, même si
ça commence à bien aller
il faut beaucoup s’investir.
Y’a pas de recette miracle
y’a pas de trucs qui va te dire,
ça c’est drôle ou ça c’est pas drôle
y’a que le public qui va te le dire.
du coup, ça tu peux
l’apprendre qu’en montant sur scène.
y’a une envie farouche
une énergie, une envie, une patate
quelque chose dont t’es convaincu quoi
Si t’es convaincu, ça va rouler.
Merci beaucoup de m’avoir écouté
et on accueille  le prochain
et on garde assez d’énergie
pour Djimo.
Techniquement on a pas mal de plans
où y’a Dji et JH en même temps.
Ce qu’on a fait déjà c’est
qu’on a engagé une doublure
La doublure qui ressemblait
le plus a Cyprien possible.
Sur beaucoup de plan,
on va me voir sur des amorces de dos.
La caméra sera derrière
On verra que mes mains,
mes pieds, un bout d’oreille.
Y’a pleins d’effets spéciaux différents
Y’a on tourne deux fois
la même séquence
et on coupe au milieu.
petit splitscreen
Un personnage sur fond bleu,
on le détourne, on l’incruste
Pour les interactions physiques,
c’est un peu plus compliqué à mettre en place
Notamment la scène
devant le Comedy Club
Pour cette scène là,
on a essayé de trouver une astuce
Avec la doublure de Cyprien
Qui vient faire une accroche sur son visage
On va venir effacer son bras,
juste garder son corps
et venir les mettre les uns sur les autres.
Et là le summum, carrément
On va incruster un plan
dans un autre plan en mouvement
avec un petit mapping 3D des familles
tu me dis si je dis des conneries
c’est bien vrai, c’est ça.
Je suis un peu dans l’effet spécial
Le plus compliqué c’est que
le cadre ne bouge pas
Que je puisse me changer rapidement
et surtout que je puisse changer de personnage.
Même si techniquement c’est la même personne
donc ils ont un peu le même état d’esprit
mais pendant plusieurs mois
ils ont beaucoup évolué,
y’en a un qui s’est un peu
renfermer sur lui-même
et l’autre Dji est monté sur scène
il est beaucoup mieux dans ses pompes
donc parfois je dois être
un peu stressé juste après détente
mais c’est le métier de comédien,
n’est-ce pas ?
Donc là faut absolument
apprendre le texte par coeur
ça sera mieux  pour
donner les répliques et tout
ça va doublure ?
Oh putain.
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
C’est quoi ce tournage ?
What ?
On est le 4e jour de tournage,
on est à Créteil
Là on peut pas tourner en fait
parce que y’a des manifestants
qui garde notre camion
où y’a tout le matériel,
la caméra, la lumière et tout ça.
Ces parkings là on était  bloqué avec des banderoles
On veut plus de réforme des retraites
Donc on est comme des cons,
à ne pas avoir de matériel
Donc on essaye de trouver des solutions
Mais malheureusement ça va
tout décaler de plusieurs heures.
donc ça va se ressentir
sur l’énergie.
Je reste tous les jours sur le tournage,
et j’assiste Cyprien,
parce que quand il est comédien
il peut pas regarder le combo,
il peut pas regarder tout ce qui se passe à l’image
il peut pas se diriger lui-même.
Timothée Hochet qui m’a dirigé
dans le court-métrage LA SCIENCE DE L’AMOUR
Pour moi il était
un peu taillé pour ça
Je lui ai dit “je tourne ça,
mais je le réalise
et je fais plusieurs
personnages à l’intérieur
il faut quelqu’un qui
soit derrière le moniteur
et qui puisse me dire,
vas-y teste cette réplique là
teste ce jeu là
Oh putain, il est là lui.
Ah c’est moins souple
que de la jambe gauche
- On peut pas être parfait.
- On l’a travaillé ensemble
C’était super, on a eu
des décors qui sont top
Le Comedy Club, le Paname
qui sont des lieux
emblématiques pour le stand-up
T’as vu comment
on fait des bijouteries ici ?
C’est le Paname,
on a fait 3 décors ici
Le Paname, la petite salle de théâtre
Le café
La bijouterie
Il faut savoir qu’on mange ici aussi
Donc voilà, merci le Paname !
On a eu le magasin de canapé,
on a eu de l’extérieur
l’appartement est très arty
on comprend bien l’univers
du personnage de Leila
Pour les peintures de Leila
C’est l’artiste Mady,
qui nous a prêté ses toiles
et son matériel
des pinceaux, des esquisses
des chiffons
Son univers graphique
est parfait pour le personnage
C’est élégant, c’est féminin.
J’ai eu la chance d’avoir
pas mal de figurants
c’est cool de pouvoir
inclure sa communauté
des gens qui t’apprécient
dans tes propres projets
Pas tout le monde peu faire ça,
donc j’ai sauté sur l’occasion
et bien je vous annonce
que c’était le dernier plan de Cyprien
et Mickael, et c’est
une fin de tournage !
Bravo !
On est pas sur Youtube là.
C’est pas pour internet ce qu’il fait
C’est du cinoche.
Suis mon doigt, abonne-toi.
Abonne-toi, sinon
je vais chez oit et je te brûle.
Non je rigole.